Brad Neuberg: Hey, so,
my name's Brad Neuberg.
I'm with the Open Web
Advocacy Team.
I'm here with my good friend
and colleague, Dion Almaer.
Dion Almaer: Hey.
Neuberg:
From Mozilla Foundation.
Almaer: Good to be here, Brad.
Good to be here back at I/O.
It's always fun.
Neuberg: So you're working
on this amazing project, Bespin,
and why don't you tell us
a bit about what it is,
what you're doing.
Almaer: Sure. So Bespin
is a project that came out
when my partner in crime,
Ben Galbraith,
we founded Ajaxian.com
together,
and we've kind of been,
you know,
talking up all these web
technologies over time, right?
And we wanted to see...
let's actually build something
that's on these new HTML5
fancy technologies
and like, what would
that world be like?
We care passionately
about developers,
so what would be
a cool developer tool?
So we created this Mozilla
Developer Tools Lab,
so luckily, we've got
the word lab in there,
so it means we can kind of
experiment and play around.
And we want to take an app
that people
aren't used to on the Web.
So we thought,
how 'bout an editor,
a coding experience
for developers.
So that's one of those things--
especially developers can be
a bit cranky sometimes.
There's no "I'm never
giving up my Emacs,"
and like,
"That'll never work on the Web."
Neuberg: Pry it from
my dead, cold hands.
Almaer: Yeah, exactly,
so it's like...
what would the world be like?
Could we build something
that was ready?
So that's really
what Bespin is.
It's this like
social coding experience
using all of like the shiny,
shiny technologies.
'Cause we've seen a few
like little code editors
on the Web,
and they never
would like scale,
and you'd get little
beach balls on large files
and it never quite
felt right.
So frankly, we wanted to see
like what could be done there.
Neuberg: So let's say
I'm a coder and I've got vi.
What are some really
compelling things
that would make me
sort of let that go
and say let me check out
Bespin
and see what's going on there?
Almaer: Yeah, so the first
thing would be
our supplementing a vi mode,
probably.
Neuberg: Okay. Step one.
Almaer: Yeah.
And we wanna have vi mode,
Emacs mode, all that stuff.
Neuberg: Word Perfect bindings?
Almaer: World Perfect [laughs].
Yeah, that little sheet
that you can put
on the top of the computer.
But seriously, though,
we actually do wanna get like...
that kinda world in.
And also, we're not trying
to like...
take people away from
their editor so much.
It's kind of
a different world.
It's complementary to your id,
your experience in some way.
So what we're trying
to focus on,
rather than build yet another id
with a million features,
we're trying to pinpoint
some really fun,
compelling features
for web developers
specifically, right?
So with Bespin,
you've got this really fast
social editor that allows you
to very easily collaborate
on code.
So earlier today, you guys--
Neuberg: Collaborate on code?
I thought you were just
supposed to sit in a closet
and type by yourself.
Almaer: Exactly, yeah,
it's like no one can see.
But you just announced
Google Wave,
which is all about
this real-time collaboration.
We can use those APIs.
We already have our own,
but we're happy to integrate
with other things.
So now...so you're doing
a code review--
Instead of like,
here's my code, click,
goes off to a code review,
patch land,
then later on, it comes back
it's like, "Hey, Brad,
do you wanna check out
the code with me?"
Real-time, right?
And there's a chat window
built in.
So you're chatting on it,
and it's associated
with the code,
with the file
and where that code is.
So say a month later
someone comes over and is like,
who did this function?
You can just select
the function
and say, oh, Dion and Brad
did it together,
and here's what they
talked about right there.
Right? So we really
associate the stuff.
Go back in time,
and there's this playback API
in Wave.
We had a similar notion
where
you're looking
at the source code,
and you can just
go back in time.
It shows you commits
for that file with tags,
and you just kinda go back
and see what happened.
Replaying the events themselves.
We're working on a project
together.
I go off to the doctor
and come back.
What's Brad been doing?
Neuberg: Right.
Almaer: Just, like,
hit replay, right?
Neuberg: Then you can come
blame...come blame the guy.
Almaer: Exactly! Yeah,
instead of staring
at divs from commits,
like what's happening.
And one of the features
I really like is
I want a world where
like we're working on something
and you just clobber
a function that I'm in too,
and I see that, alert, alert,
Brad was just in here--
I want to commit quickly
so you have to do the merge.
Neuberg: Yeah.
Almaer: Right?
Like all these little things
that we can do now
we're kind of aware
of what's going on.
So...it's fun stuff.
Neuberg:
So there's this notion--
I think a lot of developers
out there
get this idea
of programming for the Web.
We like to call it--
it's programming
for the 1997 version of the Web.
You had the really nice
experience of programming
for the 2009 version
of the Web.
I know you've been able to use
all these modern facilities,
modern aspects of JavaScript.
How has that experience been?
Almaer: Yeah, it's been
awesome, man.
It's like taking off
the shackles, right?
And that's one of the reasons
we all wanted to do
a develop-ery thing,
because developers
haven't come to us saying,
"I need this in IE6!"
Neuberg: So just to be clear,
that's also true.
So currently, Bespin is only
supported on modern browsers.
Almaer: Yes.
Neuberg: Specifically Firefox,
at this point.
Almaer: Firefox, Safari...
Neuberg: Safari now as well.
Almaer: There's a few weird
things with Chrome and canvas,
but most of it works.
Neuberg: So you're
not shackled by sort of
backwards compatibility...
Almaer: Exactly.
Neuberg: So what are
some of those--
what has been one of
the nicest limitations
that you're free of now?
Almaer: So...the debugging
experience has totally changed.
It's amazing how close
the modern browsers
actually are, right?
So like in the past,
you're always doing it
and there's like these
weird bugs and IE6
and this, that,
and the other,
and you spend
all your time on that.
Even though there's still
subtle differences,
like I'll give you one--
we do a lot of stuff with
the Web Worker API, right?
But what browsers
is that in, first.
So we created a facade that
if you've got workers, great.
If not, try and use Gears.
Neuberg: Yeah.
Almaer: If not,
we'll just do setInterval
and just make the code
actually run,
but it's not gonna be great.
But then within the browsers,
Safari doesn't support
importScripts,
part of the Web Worker API,
so we implement that
in the facade.
So you're Mr. Shim,
you understand this world.
And so we did the same thing
for workers
so you can just go ahead
and use the same worker API.
And there's all these subtle
little things with workers
like...we do real-time
syntax analysis
and so we have JSLint
built in, for example.
So as you're typing,
it's like...
tells you the error right then.
Neuberg: That's run in a worker.
Almaer: And it's run
in a worker.
Neuberg: So it doesn't block
the execution of the script.
Almaer: Exactly. Otherwise,
you'd be typing and be frozen.
So we've got a whole bunch
of these, like, smart agents
so we can kick off
the workers.
But then we started to see
the CPU usage go like crazy.
'Cause we're not restricted
to this, like, single thread
in the main UI thread
in the browser.
We can start firing stuff off.
But now that's using up
all of the browsers,
and it's counteractive.
So there's no notion
of yield and stuff like that,
which I really want now.
Neuberg: Yeah. Asleep...
Almaer: Asleep.
Exactly, yeah.
And so what we have to do
if we have different slicings
where we go through
and we monitor how many workers.
So this code, this facade,
is all open source in Bespin,
so if people are interested
in, like, doing worker stuff,
it's there,
and we want to break it off
into its own
open source project.
So being able to use workers
has given us...a huge win for--
'cause we can start doing
all these things
that we'd never even
be able to do before.
Neuberg: You mentioned
something I want to highlight
and most people
don't expect--
sort of the modern browsers,
Safari, Chrome, Firefox,
are actually
very similar to each other.
Almaer: Yeah.
Neuberg: And I heard a statistic
that I didn't realize
from someone recently...
Firefox 2 turned over
to Firefox 3.
Within two months, 50%
of the audience flipped over.
Almaer: Yeah.
Neuberg: I hadn't...
I just learned about this
recently.
Almaer: Yeah, that's cool.
Neuberg: So these browsers
are revving
faster than people expect
so you can use these
newer features
faster than you'd expect.
Almaer:
And there's kind of
this weird chicken and egg
situation, right,
where it's like, if we don't
go and build apps
using canvas
and all these things,
then why is it worth switching
from IE6?
Neuberg: Exactly.
It's a tricky...
Almaer: But like we gotta
get it out and push.
I know it's really hard
for consumer apps and stuff,
but I'm trying to, like,
get it there
and then give people
a reason to operate.
Neuberg: Right, right.
Almaer: But then, like...
with a fast JavaScript,
that alone was a huge thing.
Canvas, we even saw
a few interesting things like--
we got this huge speed bump
when it was testing
on WebKit nightly.
One day it just, like,
instantly was faster.
Neuberg: Interesting.
Almaer: And we're like,
well, what changed?
Well, what actually
turned out was
the canvas implementation...
they made an adjustment
to the algorithm
where it only blit
the changes on the canvas
instead of painting
all the time.
Neuberg: So it had
a dirty flag?
Almaer: Yeah, exactly.
And so in an editor,
that's like heaven.
Because most of the time
you're typing,
and all you need to do
is add in...the text.
Neuberg: Right.
Almaer: And so again,
we're benefiting
from all these browsers
kind of innovating,
and we solved this speed bump
for nothing.
And we were also doing
a lot of techniques like--
we didn't think
that having, like,
one huge canvas full-screen
would scale.
Like, we didn't think
it would perform.
And that turned out
not to be a bottleneck at all.
We now have multiple
canvases, actually,
like we have this pine menu
Quicksilver thing
that animates on--
it's actually on top.
Neuberg: You just use
z-index and...
Almaer: Yeah. And again, we're
like, is this gonna like...
you know, be weird?
Not at all.
It performs fantastically.
Neuberg: Interesting.
Almaer: The funny story
about bottlenecks is, um...
Neuberg: Yeah. They're always--
Almaer: There's always--yeah.
Neuberg: They're never
where you expect them.
Almaer: Exactly.
We made a big mistake
in that the day before
we shipped Bespin,
we have this syntax
highlighter,
so obviously,
you go through.
We just, as you do,
we grabbed an open source WAN
that's kind of
in the model of
you write a bunch of code
into a text area,
hit something,
it shows you pretty HTMLs.
One of those guys, right, like
you use in a blog or something.
So we took that code
and started to use it,
but for us, we're painting
again and again.
And so every time
we paint that line,
we're doing syntax analysis
to do the highlighting.
And we profiled it
and it was doing, like,
500 regex per line,
and we're painting every
10 milliseconds or whatever.
So we're doing thousands
of regular expressions.
Neuberg:
Was it a compiled regex?
Did you reuse your regex object?
Almaer: We would reuse
the regex object,
but it was, like,
different ones going on,
and it's just, like,
just an immense--
every 10 milliseconds,
thousands of regexes, right?
Neuberg: Yeah.
Almaer: And so we're like,
this is nuts.
We've gotta skip that.
And so we wrote our own
state-based state machine,
very simple syntax
highlighter.
And like we have
our unit test,
and it's like, here's the one
that we had at first
and here's our new one,
and it's, like,
thousands times faster.
And then we go
check it out again,
and it turns out
it barely made a difference
to the responsiveness
at all.
Because we were so worried that
we had all this JavaScript code
that's doing
all the canvas stuff
that that would be
the bottleneck.
JavaScript
wasn't the bottleneck at all.
It was all the blitting it to
the screen was the bottleneck.
Neuberg: Right, interesting.
I know, it's always...
measure...
do your measurements first,
and then actually do
your optimization.
Almaer: Exactly, yeah.
So that again kind of hit home
that JavaScript isn't the
bottleneck that it used to be.
Neuberg: No, especially
when we start using
the newer things
like canvas, SVG,
blitting to the screen.
You know what,
that's always the bottleneck,
The DOM is the bottleneck,
so generally...
Almaer: Yeah.
But yeah, it's...
it's been kind of fun
to ignore the DOM sometimes too.
That's again,
like the canvas API is so small,
that being able
to just have that--
Neuberg: That should be
a bumper sticker!
Or a T-shirt--
"I'm ignoring the DOM.
What are you gonna
do about it?"
Almaer: It's kind of funny,
like--
one version,
we're using jQuery,
which is
a fantastic library.
But we realized it wasn't
doing anything for us
because it's all about DOM.
Neuberg: It's all about DOM.
Almaer: DSL for the DOM, so...
Yeah, fun things
have come out of it like
we've started to play around
with this Thunderhead UI toolkit
that goes,
okay, you got canvas,
you got this thing
to draw things,
but how do you put
these components--
there's no component
hierarchy.
And it's been really fun
to get to play around with that.
And we re-use CSS,
and we now have implemented
a bunch of the CSS3 stuff.
So the developer
just uses even, like,
-webkit-transform,
or whatever, and it works,
and we've implemented it
in canvas.
Neuberg: Right,
reversing it and--
Almaer: And what's so cool
is that, like,
man, I wish we had
this CSS3 feature...
we just do it.
Neuberg: Yeah.
Almaer: And implement it.
Neuberg: Take the future
in your own hands.
Almaer:
Yeah, yeah, it's cool.
Neuberg: We're almost
out of time, unfortunately.
There's way more
interesting stuff here
that we can talk about
in eight minutes,
but if people want to learn more
and want to get involved,
I know you've been really
great about pulling people in,
new contributions.
How do they get started?
Where do they go?
Almaer: Yeah, so the main site
for Bespin
is bespin.mozilla.com.
That's where you'll go
to kind of see
the flagship product.
But there's actually
different pieces,
so if you like the editor,
there's an editor component.
It's all open source.
Neuberg: It's a la carte.
Almaer: Exactly.
You can use the servers.
Everything is there available.
We have a Wiki
on wiki.mozilla.org/labs/bespin.
Has all of the information,
our IRC channel, mailing lists,
and we'd love for you
to come help contribute
to the platform.
Neuberg: So just in the last
five seconds,
what's been one really cool
external contribution,
and who's the contributor
that you've really liked?
Almaer: Yeah, so this guy
Julian--
this is actually kind of
pretty awesome--
so as an experiment--
you're an old open source guy,
so you know it's like,
how do you get contributors,
right?
Neuberg: It's not easy.
Almaer: Not easy.
So I did a little experiment
just kind of goofing around
where I was about
to add a feature,
and instead of writing
the code,
I built a fairly detailed spec,
but not too rigid,
and got the graphics all ready
and all that stuff.
And I said
this is a 50-point feature.
So I emailed the people
out there.
I was like,
anyone who can do this,
you get 50 points.
They meant nothing, right,
at this time.
And then a day later,
this guy--
Neuberg: Well, again,
this is 25 points, so...
Almaer: Yeah, exactly.
He's German, so I definitely
think he expects a beer.
Neuberg: Right.
Almaer: But...
like literally,
a day or two later,
this Julian guy from Germany
came along
and just implemented.
It was the equivalent
if you used a textme, Applet
to quickly go to a file,
he implemented Quick Open
in the editor in a day.
Like, never touched it before,
like, did all the stuff.
So it really showed us
the power.
If you give people what
they need to get stuff done,
they'll do it.
They want to do it.
They want to get involved.
Now he's been on the project
the whole time.
I believe he's still
in high school, this guy.
Neuberg: Nice. Nice.
Almaer: He's amazing.
Yeah, all the contributors--
we had syntax,
Engine staff people
have put in.
Someone ported it to Dojo,
which was a huge effort.
Now we're just like
again and again
seeing people come up
and do amazing work,
so we're jazzed.
Neuberg: So we gotta wrap up.
But he got 50 points.
If you want 100 points,
go to the site...
Almaer: Exactly.
Neuberg: I'm not saying...
I'm not signing you up
to give away free points, so...
Thank you so much, man.
Almaer: Always a pleasure,
my friend.
Neuberg: You too, my friend.
Almaer: Thank you.